[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
The idea for today's video
is brought to us by
YouTube user Dalton Wood
who wants to see us
mix iron powder into oobleck,
and then see if a magnet will
cause that oobleck too harden up.
[Music]
Not too long ago, we showed you a DIY
recipe for making some magnetic ooze.
It'll be interesting to see
if the magnetic oobleck
will get drawn into a magnet
in the same way the magnetic ooze does,
or if the non-Newtonian
fluid nature of the oobleck
will cause it to just harden up
in the presence of the magnet.
The idea for this one is very simple.
We're gonna mix up a batch of oobleck
and then try mixing in some iron oxide,
which is quite magnetic,
to see if we can make magnetic oobleck.
Will a magnet cause the oobleck to
harden up the way pushing on it does?
Or it will stretch and reach
the way magnetic putty will?
As the first step,
I think we need to mix
ourselves up some oobleck.
[Music]
Here we go.
We've got ourselves
a batch of normal oobleck,
which of course is just made from
corn starch and water mixed together,
and this stuff is so freaking cool.
I think everyone's played with this stuff.
So now, let's see
if we can make this magnetic
by adding some magnetite.
This is a synthetic black
iron oxide available online,
and we're just gonna
add a little bit of it,
and see how much we need
to add to make it magnetic.
Of course, we don't
want to add too much
because cornstarch
and water is fairly specific,
and you start adding too much
of other liquids or solids
than it doesn't react the same way.
This whole bag.
You can see is quite attracted
to a magnet.
Get some of this very fine
black powder out.
I don't know how much
of this we're going to need
to make the oobleck magnetic.
Let's start small,
and just keep adding from there.
And mixing oobleck is always loads of fun
because as soon as you start to mix it,
it turns solid.
You basically just break pieces off
and pull them on top of each other
and let it liquefy again.
It looks like cookies and cream.
[Music]
Even with just that little bit,
this feels a little bit more
crumbly than it was before.
It's still basically the same
idea but it's even more dry.
Maybe we've just had a slight
bit of evaporation.
But I think we need
to add a little bit more water.
[Music]
We've got our non-Newtonian fluid
with some of our magnetite mixed in.
But the question is if we have
enough for it to really be magnetic.
It's not even black yet.
It's dark gray.
But in the past, before we got
something really to respond to a magnet,
we had enough magnetite
in it to turn it black.
So I'm gonna try adding
just a little bit more.
[Music]
We've got our blackened
magnetite filled oobleck,
and now I think it's time to test|
whether or not this stuff is magnetic.
And if it is, what happens
when you bring a magnet near it?
I'm starting off with
a pretty darn powerful magnet
just because I really
want to see what happens
in the presence of something
that's really gonna pull on this.
So I'm gonna start by just putting
it on the outside of the bowl.
Let's see what it does on the inside.
I can see it is gathering a little bit.
It's moved over to the side.
It's not pulling on it
very strongly though.
Where if it is and it's solidifying up
so we can't see it pulling much.
Let's just bring it right next to magnet
and really see what happens here.
Oh, it's certainly pulling on it.
and that's looking quite a bit like
how it reacts to the magnetic ooze.
But I think it is actually keeping it
from turning back into a liquid.
It's constantly pulling on it enough.
You can see with just this little blob,
if I stop moving,
it starts running,
just kind of pouring
down my finger a little bit.
The magnetite, this black dust,
has a tendency to stain
very quickly and easily.
I'm going without gloves because
I want you to be able to see it really nicely
but I don't know, it might just
turn my fingers black pretty quick.
So you can see as long as I
keep this rolling around,
it's fairly solid then as soon as I stop,
it just puddles, turns into a liquid.
It's not quite as runny as it is with normal
oobleck without magnetite powder in it.
But, the same thing is working.
So now, let's see what happens
on the magnet again.
Put it on the magnet.
And it does seem to be holding it still.
It's not running off
the way it was in my fingers.
Let's just grab another little
blob about the same size.
So my fingers, if I stop
doing anything with it,
see it begins to run.
But the stuff on the magnet
is being held in place.
It's staying fairly solid.
In fact, I can even poke it
and feel that it feels fairly solid.
But when I have strands dripping down,
it really does pull on it in a similar
manner to our magnetic ooze.
Here, I've got a batch of the same
magnetic slime that we mixed up previously,
and this is our newly-made
magnetic oobleck.
Let's look at the differences
between how these react.
So magnetic slime, magnet,
see it starts pretty well.
Here stretching stuff.
As a comparison, our magnetic oobleck.
It does
start to move very quickly.
It moves into the magnet pulling on it.
But at that point,
it doesn't pull and stretch the
way our magnetic slime does.
[Music]
To get a little bit of it,
I have to hold the magnet closer,
move it around a bit,
and it's definitely slower
but we are getting from
stretch out of our oobleck.
So definitely a very different
type of stretching
we see with our magnetic ooze.
[Music]
So our two giant magnets inside
of our two magnetic semi-fluids
do behave differently.
This one over here is the slime,
and we were able to see that
that slime very quickly reached up
and grabbed all the way around the
magnet surrounding it, engulfing it.
It is just completely suspended
in the magnetic slime right now.
Magnetic oobleck,
it did some similar things
but it didn't do nearly
as much as the slime did.
As the magnet started pulling it together,
I believe it did start hardening the Oobleck
the same way as when you play with it
or roll it around or poke it really hard.
And because of that,
not too much of the substance was able
to start climbing up around the magnet.
But I did find that when I started
taking the bowl and vibrating it,
it sort of made the oobleck
into the state of liquefaction,
where became more runny,
and suddenly it began climbing up
the sides of the magnet a lot faster.
It was also fun because the whole magnet
started sliding toward the other magnet.
They're about eight inches apart,
and they're starting to pull each other.
So the magnetic oobleck
does definitely harden up.
The magnet powder in
there not only changes
the consistency of the oobleck a little bit
but it also makes it react to a magnet,
and it seizes up and becomes
a lot more hard and durable,
and in fact, just poking this spot over here
feels a lot softer than the part
that's touching the magnet itself.
I also thought it was fun.
As I was moving the bowls,
I noticed that the magnets like to
stay pointed towards each other.
So if I turn the magnet in the slime,
themagnet starts just rotating,
dragging all the slime with it.
Another interesting thing
happening right now
is that the magnet is pulling on some
of the oobleck with magnetite powder in it
so hard that it's actually squeezing
some of the water out of it.
This is a similar issue to what we ran into
when we were trying to make
magnetic fluid, a ferrofluid,
and it's that a lot of the time,
the magnet is so strong
it squeezes the particulate
together so hard
that the water doesn't have
space in between little particles,
and it just starts dripping out.
Dalton Wood, you wanted to know
whether or not we could add iron powder
and make magnetic oobleck.
The answer is mostly we can.
It does change the consistency,
so it's not quite the
same as normal oobleck
but it does still form
a ball when you play with it,
and puddle out when you
stop moving it around.
It's not quite as firm or quite
as liquid either side,
but it is still a non-Newtonian fluid
and it does get pulled by a magnet.
And yes, the pull of the magnet
does cause it to harden it.
So good question, fun experiment to try.
Thank you for your suggestion.
Check your YouTube inbox Dalton,
we're gonna be sending you 25 bucks.
Guys it's not over.
We've got more for you to see.
That box up at the top will transport
you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box in the bottom will show you what
YouTube thinks you need to be watching next,
and this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe you to the channel,
that way you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.